so let's talk a little bit about the
element phosphorus and it's important to
life and how it cycles through living
systems so we're going to talk about the
phosphorus cycle so first it's important
to appreciate that phosphorus is a very
reactive element so it's seldom found by
itself normally we find it in phosphate
form so this right over here the orange
is a phosphorus atom and it's bound to
four oxygens right over here and at
least the way that it's set up right
over here
it would have a negative three charge
and so this would have this would often
form ionic bonds with other things or
one of the oxygens can have a covalent
bond or you can form phosphoric acid
where the oxygen is bound to hydrogen's
but this is the general form that you
typically find it so that's the
phosphorus that I'm pointing to but this
whole thing we would call this a
phosphate we would call this a phosphate
and you see this showing up in very
important macromolecules in biology this
is DNA and both DNA and RNA have
phosphate backbones you can see the the
sides of the ladder I guess you could
view it is that way or the backbone of
our DNA molecules you can see these
phosphates there and it's the center of
the phosphate you have that phosphorus
the phosphorus atom also over here you
have ATP in biology we study that it's
the powerhouse it's the energy currency
of biological systems stands for
adenosine triphosphate you have three
phosphate groups right over here and
when you pluck one of those phosphate
groups off it can power reactions it can
change the conformation of enzymes it
can do all sorts of interesting things
so hopefully you can appreciate that
phosphate is essential for life because
life as we know it involves ATP and
involves DNA and many many other things
that phosphates are involved with now
phosphate or a phosphorus I should say
in particular is a little bit different
than carbon or nitrogen and that it's
not found in the atmosphere it's not
typically found in as a gas instead
phosphate is going to be formed is going
to be found in
rocks and it's going to be phosphate
based rocks there will be other elements
in there could be chlorine it could be
well there's there's a bunch of
different types of phosphate rocks but
when when they're in their sedimentary
form so let me create some soil here so
let's say this soil has some phosphates
in it well then it allows things like
plants to grow in that soil so this is a
plant growing in that soil and the plant
and we've talked about it before it
could be it could be taking its fixing
carbon from the atmosphere using light
energy but its phosphate is going to
come from the soil that phosphate was
already there and that helps that plant
grow because that plant needs that
phosphate for its ATP it's DNA it's RNA
and for other things and phosphate is
often considered a rate limiting factor
for the growth of things like plants and
that's why a lot of fertilizers will
have will have phosphorus in them or
phosphates or will and nitrogen is
another one so what next time you think
about fertilizer you're fertilizing
things regarde look at the ingredients
you will see phosphate there because
that might be the scarce resource or the
thing that is limiting the actual growth
of the plant and then you might say well
I have ATP and DNA in my body how do I
get phosphates well you get it by eating
plants so this is this is you eating a
plant so the plant goes back there and
how how does this form a cycle
well when any of this living matter dies
and I've said in previous video also the
dead plant because a dead animal is it's
just a little darker so whenever you see
so this is a plant now it's dead let's
say it got buried somehow some soil so
it's all this is the dead plant right
over there well it's the the phosphate
in that plant can then go back into the
soil so you could view this as a very
tight cycle and the same thing would be
once you die or I die the phosphates if
we're buried would go into the soil but
there could be other ways that the that
the the phosphate and and the
corresponding phosphorus gets recycled
you think on a on a bigger scale
where you could have a let's say that
this let's say there's a river there's a
river right over here this is either a
very small river or a very big plant I
drew and so that River can take
phosphates from that soil and it could
put it into the ocean and then those
phosphates could be used by sea life and
then when that sea life dies it goes to
the base of the ocean floor and at some
point in the future that base of the
ocean for could be pushed up and a plant
grows on it so you can imagine all sorts
of these cycles and we're actually
seeing more and more of this as human
beings have said hey if phosphate is the
rate limiting factor for the growth of
plants and we need to grow a lot of
plants in order to feed ourselves well
we've started mining it and we've
started adding a lot more to the soil
but it also allows a lot of that to get
to be washed away into our rivers and
streams and eventually end up in the
ocean and as we'll see this can actually
have very negative negative consequences
for our biosphere